move on so our next speaker today is a
former kitaev student who's now a
professor of computer science at the
University of Chicago where they've
worked extensively on topics in qualm
complexity quantum algorithms
cryptography and quantum computing so
today bill pfefferman will now speak to
us about a rather timely topic which is
the power of random qualm circuits so
it's all yours bill all right thanks a
lot
r-ryan let me just make sure do people
hear what I'm saying
ok ok awesome I'm going to share my
screen and then let's see I think I'm
going to stop my video if that's ok I
think it's sort of my bandwidth is
limited unfortunately ok so now let me
let me start
oops wait hold on ok good so we also see
my slides we do right yes very good all
right wonderful
so ok so so I'm going to talk about the
the power of random quantum circuits you
know I want to talk about this topic
from sort of two perspectives and I
think they're complimentary and it's
very interesting to see them sort of
interplay with each other the one is a
perspective of hardness and this is
joint with Adam Boland Qin menurkey and
bhoomesh Maserati and then the second is
is it is an easiness perspective and
it's very new work sort of numerical
work with kim juno and liang jing at
UChicago ok so the starting point of
this talk as we know we've sort of
arrived at this very exciting era in
which existing quantum experiments can
solve problems that seem challenging for
classical computers what this means you
know is that experiments are now large
enough so that the best known classical
simulation techniques take a large
amount of time on classical
supercomputers but at the same time
these experiments have you know
important limitations which could
potentially be exploited by faster
classical algorithms right so for
example they have restricted depth or
uncorrect annoys and you know from the
perspective of you know a classical
stimulation algorithm this is
adding structure to the simulation
problem and we want to be sure that
we're sort of not inadvertently adding
too much structure and we don't have
unexpected algorithms for simulating
these problems all right so of course
the first goal for this near-term era is
what we call quantum supremacy and this
has been the topic of the last two days
it needs no introduction by itself but
you know I will say that when you try to
define what this actually means it's a
bit subtle right I think notoriously so
so let me try to say what I think it
should mean I think we should try to
find a task that simultaneously can be
solved experimentally on near-term
hardware but also is classically hard
and I think this is the tricky part you
know I think this should mean both that
there's good theoretical or asymptotic
hardness evidence from complexity theory
they you know as the size of the system
scales there's no polynomial and end
time algorithm that solves this problems
that's generally what we mean by
hardness as a complexity theorist but
you know we also want you know something
a little bit more pragmatic which is
that at the end of the day we're
implementing this and you know the
experiment is implementing this for some
fixed system size and so we want to be
sure that we can't solve this problem in
a comparable amount of time by a
classical supercomputer right so of
course these two things are related to
each other but I think they're they're
somewhat different and then of course we
want a procedure for verification right
we we need to be sure that we're solving
the problem correctly okay great so what
is okay so we already have a question is
that right oh no okay fine all right so
what is what is Google's approach but
it's this random circuit sampling
proposal which you've already heard
about in Sergio's talk and in many of
the talks you know which which from my
perspective is the following this is
admittedly a bit idealized we wanted
general we ought to generate a quantum
circuit on a 2d lattice with let's say
square root and layers of har random
nearest neighbor gates right so if you
look at my pictures sort of how a
theorist thinks about you know quantum
experiment the dots here are
our cubits the the edges are you know
two cubit har random nearest neighbor
gates and and you know this is a single
layer but of course in reality we can
have you know a square root and number
of different layers then the next layer
for example the gates could act on
horizontal neighbors instead of vertical
neighbors right so they could all be
different and then we start in the all
zero input state we apply a random
quantum circuit with you know square
root and of these of these layers and we
measure in the computational basis and
that's our sampling problem okay so
we're sampling from the output
distribution of this random Quantum's
okay great so from the perspective of
quantum supremacy you know why are
random circuits an attractive proposal
right why might we have why might you
know Google have chosen to do this well
I think there's many reasons first of
all of course it's experimentally
feasible and I think from a theoretical
perspective this is sort of wrapped up
with the fact that we're we're
reasonably optimistic that this problem
is hard at comparatively low depth and
system size okay we won't be too
specific about this at this point but
this is this is important right and then
I think also there are important
advantages for verification and
benchmarking of random circuits and most
of these come from you know the fact
that the output distribution of random
circuits have what we call the porter
thomas property which is essentially
saying for if you fix an outcome x then
the probability over the choice of
random circuit that that outcome there
the probability of that outcome
occurring after measurement you know is
equal to Q over N is exponentially
distributed in Q okay so that's the
porter thomas property and this is we
can we can use this property to
calculate the ideal score of a random
circuit on benchmarking tests so in a
nutshell this is how Google understands
what their ideal cross entropy score
should be it comes from this porter
thomas property which then itself is
inherited from a random quantum circuit
okay so but okay so that's great that's
why random circuits are sort of
appealing in the near term but of course
you know as complexity theorists what we
want to know
is is deeper you know why should this be
a hard task and you know I think again
from a high level in the last maybe 10
or so years we as a community have given
good evidence that this random circuit
sampling problem is classically hard at
least in the noiseless case ok and this
is not at all obvious I mean if you
think about it you know prior quantum
algorithms don't look anything like a
random circuit necessarily right and so
even in the noiseless case is an
interesting problem and so starting with
this paper that you know I think again
it is was way ahead of its time it's
like six years before anyone else
thought about this idea again really
after Hall D Vincenzo and then this this
this later paper by Bremner Choza and
Shepard what they're doing essentially
is in my language establishing
worst-case hardness of sampling results
so what they're saying roughly speaking
is that there's some restrictive class
of circuits with the property that clad
if there is a classical algorithm that
could sample from the output
distribution of all of those circuits
you know then the polynomial time
hierarchy would collapse ok so there's
good hardness evidence that this doesn't
is not the case
all right then there's this famous paper
by Aronson and arkhipov from my
perspective this is the first paper that
really considered random quantum
circuits but they were considering it in
a very special setting this ozone
sampling setting where these random
circuits had you know very special
properties ok they were they came from
linear optics and there is a connection
to the permanent and so on I when
there's Arrington Chen you know this is
talking about the hardness of scoring
well on a benchmark test like
cross-entropy or a hog test and then
we'll talk about this this paper of this
next paper very shortly ok no what I
want to say though is these were really
I think fundamentally in the sort of
noiseless case and it's possible that
these arguments will carry over to the
noisy case but I think I think it's fair
to say that we're less certain about
this it generally requires sort of
non-standard hardness conjectures that I
think may well be true and we can try to
give evidence for them but again I think
it's fair to say that the community is
not really there's not totally familiar
with these these hardness arguments and
it's not something like P equal and
P or something that we at least have a
lot of experience dealing with okay so
what are we going to do today well I'm
going to try to be a little bit more
conservative I'm going to take what
might seem would you know might seem to
be sort of a step back and I want to
consider the hardness of computing the
outcome probabilities of potentially
noisy random circuits all right now when
we consider in you know when we go from
the problem that in some sense we care
about which is sampling to to this
harder problem of computing output
probabilities well as you would expect
there's sort of pluses and minuses right
so that's compared with sampling I would
say that you know experiments can't
efficiently solve this problem right the
experiments are sampling they're not
computing outcome probabilities you know
but at the same time because it's a hard
a harder task it's it's possible to
prove much harder strong as you know
much stronger hardness results and then
of course in practice many classical
simulation algorithms do compute output
probabilities so we can think of these
hardness results as some sort of barrier
for these algorithms okay so what are we
going to do you know so here's the
agenda I want to review the average case
sharp p hardness for the near exact
computation of the output probability of
random circuits I want to show that
these results still hold if the circuit
is noisy but in a very particular sense
which is that you have to fix the noise
model ahead of time so it's not super
strong sense right so but it but this
does work for example for local
depolarizing noise which is you know an
important noise model and then I want to
talk about new very new classical sort
of numerical simulation algorithms for
1d noisy random circuits okay so maybe
it's a good time to stop and just ask
anyone if there's questions with what
I'm trying to do okay so far so good all
right awesome so let's keep going
okay so what's the problem the problem
is this we're given as input you know a
random quantum circuit and it's
distributed from the circuit that from
the distribution we just described okay
and and now we'll be out the the the
goal is to compute the output
probability which I'm just going to call
p0 of C okay with probability one
- Delta oversee so to be completely
clear this this p0 of C quantity is just
what we get if we start in the all zeros
state we you know apply a random circuit
we measure in the standard basis and
this is the probability of seeing all
zeros again and so that's what I that's
what I mean by p0 see I'll be consistent
about that throughout the entire talk
okay so to prove this a sharpie hard we
give what we call a worst case to
average case reduction right and and
roughly speaking what it says is sort of
described in this picture which is a
little bit misleading this worst-case
circuit here could really be an
arbitrary circuit anywhere in the space
of quantum circuits but the structure of
the argument goes something like this it
says suppose we have an algorithm that
works to correctly simulate to compute
the output probability of a sufficiently
large fraction of the space of quantum
circuits okay then we can use that
ability to compute the output
probability of a worst-case or arbitrary
quantum circuit all right so this is
usually seen as sort of a proof by
contradiction we we usually understand
the worst case hardness pretty well and
we usually think of that as being hard
like sharp be hard so no algorithm could
solve this and then we say well if it
was the case that the average case was
easy then also the worst case would be
easy and so that's a contradiction
that's sort of how this argument is
going to work okay and and it's going to
build on a famous result of dick Lipton
on the average case hardness of
computing the permanent of a matrix okay
okay great so let me now go through dick
Lipton's argument there's a number of
reasons I want to do this because it's
one of my favorite proofs it's just a
beautiful proof I think everyone should
know this it's very simple but very
clever the second thing which is maybe
deeper is that I think we've been
discovering as a community now many sort
of mathematical similarities between the
permanent of a matrix and the output
probability of a quantum circuit these
are somehow I think at a high level at
least similar mathematical quantities
and I'm going to make many sort of ties
to the between these two these two
quantities all right so the permits so
first of all the permanent of an N by n
matrix a sharp be hard in the worst
cases this is the same worst case
complexity as computing the output
probability of a
I'm circuit okay so that's the first
similarity note the the permanent houses
a very simple you know algebraic
property which is that we can think of
it as a degree and polynomial on any
squared variables where the N squared
variables are the matrix entries okay so
that's easy to see from the formulation
of the permanent okay now here's the
setting that we're working in right we
you know someone tells us that we need
to compute the permanent of a worst-case
matrix right well we don't know how to
do that but we do have an average case
algorithm at our disposal by assumption
and what that out what that average case
algorithm is is an OP isn't a kind of a
faulty algorithm oh that works to
correctly compute most permanence over
the finite field we're going to work on
the finite field setting where P is
sufficiently large all right so this is
what Oh does it agrees with the
permanent on most random matrices okay
but but we have no idea what happens
when it doesn't agree to get it
completely wrong and nor do we know from
the end-user perspective using this
faulty algorithm oh we don't know when
it gets it right or wrong all we know is
that it works with a sufficiently high
probability okay and so the question is
how can we use this average case
algorithm this faulty algorithm to
simulate our worst case quantum circuit
and so that's what Lipton is trying to
do and so here's how he does it it's
sort of it's an elegant argument he's
going to choose n plus one fixed nonzero
points in our finite field so let's say
P the size of the finite fields at least
n plus one right so let's call it t1 t2
through through TN plus one and then
we're going to choose a uniformly random
matrix okay over our field I'll call
that matrix R now we're going to
consider the line a of T which is X plus
T times R ok so X is fixed that's our
worst case matrix and now we're doing a
random shift to buy R right
there's sort of two observations about
this about this line and then once you
see that the proof sort of works out for
itself so it's very nice the first
observation I called a marginal property
which is that for each I of T sub I is a
random
matrix over the finite field again
that's that sort of self-evident because
what we're doing here with with a of T
is we're taking this fixed matrix X and
we're shifting by something random right
so at least from the perspective of a
finite field we get a uniform or a
random matrix if we sort of lose where
we started where we started the fact
that we we have X there all right and
then the second property is that there's
a univariate polynomial structure here
and this is going to sort of allow us to
recover the word the permanent of the
worst case matrix using the permanent of
a whole bunch of of random matrices
right and that's just that the permanent
of a of T is a degree n polynomial in
this single variable T ok that's not
surprising either that comes from the
algebraic property of the permanent
right the fact that the permanent is a
degree and polynomial in N squared
variables right so now this is a degree
n polynomial in the single variable T ok
but the point is this as you know by the
fundamental theorem of algebra right we
have a degree n polynomial we have n
plus 1 points and so these evaluation
points uniquely define this degree n
polynomial so it's possible to use sort
of error correction or you can even
think about it as polynomial
interpolation techniques to sort of take
these n plus 1 evaluations of our debris
and polynomial recover the coefficients
of the polynomial and then and then
evaluate the polynomial at T equals 0
and because a when when a of 0 is equal
to X this is our permanent of our worst
case matrix ok so very nice argument
it's a little bit slick it's so so any
any sort of questions here ok are we
good see
we do have some quiet I've heard it I
will talk about some of these questions
later from the QA okay great
so now what we're trying to do is adapt
this proof to the random to the random
quantum circuit setting okay so the
first thing we noticed this is another
similarity between the permanent and the
output probability of a quantum circuit
which is just is that much like the
permanent of a matrix X the output
probability of a random quantum circuit
or for that matter quantum circuits in
general have a sort of low degree or
moderate degree polynomial structure
okay so how are we going to see this
let's consider taking a circuit an
arbitrary circuit and breaking it apart
into its gates okay so so cmcm minus 1
through c1 those are the gates of the
circuit maybe they're there two qubit
gates it doesn't matter well I'm going
to claim that that polynomial structure
comes from the Fineman path integral
okay which allows us to write the output
amplitude of this quantum circuit as
this giant sum over pads okay these are
values of these Y variables and there's
an exponential number of paths but the
important point is that the value of
each path is the product of M gate
entries okay that's that's what the
Fineman path integral allows us to do
we're just inserting sort of identity
gates really here it's really what we're
doing and the thing to notice right away
is that this is very similar in some
ways to the expression of the permanent
I just said you know this is a
polynomial of degree M in the gate
entries of the circuit right where m is
the size of the circuit okay and so in
particular by the born rule you know the
output probability of the circuit this p
0 of C is it is a polynomial of degree 2
times out right it's not surprising
we're just square we're just squaring
the amplitude okay great so we now have
polynomial structure so let's try to to
take this structure and just blindly
copy Lipton's proof well any time you do
this you know almost every time you do
this in math it doesn't end up working
we're going to need to do something
smarter than this but let's see why what
we would do so again let's just recall
what the goal
we want to compute the output
probability of a worst case circuit see
uh but we're only we only have the
ability to compute the output
probabilities for most for most circuits
yeah that's that we only have an average
case faulty algorithm that does this for
most random circuits so let's recall
what lipton did well he wanted to
compute the permanent of a matrix X and
he chose a random matrix R and then
considered this line X plus T times R
right the problem is and sort of obvious
you know we can't we can't just perturb
quantum gates in a random linear
direction that's because you know
unitary matrices aren't linear you can't
take a unitary C which is maybe your
your worst case unitary take a random
unitary B and then take C plus T times D
and expect that to be a unitary that's
obviously not the case so we can't do
that okay so that that fails so what we
need is sort of a new approach to
scrambling the gates of a fixed of a
fixed quantum circuit like our
worst-case quantum circuits C ok so
here's here's a new method this method
will also not quite work but it gets us
a little closer to what we want let's
consider choosing and then fixing my
random gates which each one you know
each one and say two qubits and I call
them H I so there's one har random gate
chose an independent leaper ideal gate
in our circuit okay so now what we're
going to do is consider a new circuit
which I call C prime okay
so that each gate in this sort of
scrambled circuit C prime sub I is
defined to be the ithe gate of our ideal
circuit times H I that's totally ramp
our random gate and notice that right
away by the invariance property of the
haar measure you know each gate in C
prime is completely random right its
horror and 'm and so this is of course
good because this is the analog of
Lipton's marginal property right that
you know we've sort of forgotten where
we start with but where we started more
completely random but the problem is you
know Lipton didn't just scramble things
he also had this sort of nice univariate
polynomial structure that connected the
worst-case circuit C with the new sir
with the scrambled circuit c-prime we
don't have that here okay so so that's
not going to work but it's given it's
getting us closer and what we need is
what I'm going to call correlating a
whole bunch of random circuits via
quantumness so what what do I mean by
that well again we're trying to find the
analog to Lipton's univariate polynomial
structure and so the main idea is we're
going to do this sort of uniquely
quantum thing which i think is is is
it's pretty cool so we can take
quantumly it makes sense to to implement
a tiny fraction of it of the h i inverse
or you know tiny fraction of a unitary
matrix particularly going to apply that
to the inverse of these random gates so
so here's what I mean let's consider a
new way of scrambling our worst-case
circuits see each scrambled gate C prime
sub I is going to be CI that's the ideal
that's the ideal gate of the ice circuit
C times H I now as before we're
completely scrambled but now we're going
to implement a tiny fraction like a
theta fraction of the inverse of this
random gate H I okay and now I'm going
to claim that this sort of has a Lipton
like structure to it so what do I mean
by this well what I mean is that if
theta is equal to 1 ok then the
corresponding circuit right is exactly
equal to the worst-case circuit I hope
that's clear that's because we're just
inverting the H I right
but if theta is really tiny let's say
it's inverse polynomial right in the
system size then each gate is really
close to horror andum right is it clear
why because essentially what you're
doing is taking your worst-case gate
you're scrambling it and then you're
doing almost nothing ok and ok so now
what you can hope to do is the following
which is very Lipton like again you can
hope to take several non zero but tiny
theta for each one of those theta you
you you know you get a different random
but correlated circuit okay I mean you
take a whole bunch of different theta
for each day to a whole bunch of you
know you for each theta you have a
different sort of scrambled circuit and
then you can hope to applies apply some
sort of polynomial interpolation at the
end of the day to recover the output
probability of the worst case circuit
okay so that's an idea it turns out not
to work and the reason is because e to
the e to the minus IH I theta is not a
polynomial in theta okay so what are we
going to do well the solution we propose
is to take is to take a fixed truncation
of the Taylor series for e to the minus
I H I theta okay all right and now so
okay so in other words what do I mean
let's be really careful so what I mean
is each each gate in the scrambled
circuit now and then we're changing it
slightly right we're now it's now going
to be C I times H I again that's
completely scrambled now instead of
instead of applying the theta power of
of the inverse of H I we're going to
we're going to consider the truncated
Taylor series for this gate okay so what
did we gain here well now you know the
gate each gate entry can be seen to be a
polynomial in theta that's because the
Taylor series itself is a polynomial in
theta right and and then why the Fineman
path integral what we're essentially
doing is you know we can write the
output probability of this new truncated
circuit C prime as a big sum over
products of these gate entries right and
that preserves the polynomial structure
as well right so the output probability
of the truncated circuit ends up being a
polynomial in theta okay of degree that
somehow out you know related to the size
of the circuit right but C prime is not
unitary any mess yes C prime is not
quite unitary more about this coming but
absolutely thank you okay so so but but
now we can we can hope to to take a
whole bunch of of Thetas small Thetas
right you know each one of them looks
for each one of them we have a scrambled
circuit C sub theta right those C sub
Thetas look very close to random right
and and and so we can hope to use our
our faulty algorithm that works with
high probability for a random circuit to
compute the output probabilities of
those random looking circuits C theta
okay and then we can hope to
interpolate find this polynomial Q in
theta and and and and output the value
of theta at theta equal one which is the
output probability of our worst-case
circuit C okay so yes I agree this is
not in unit area we'll talk about that
that's sort of a very interesting issue
here but any other questions about what
we're doing okay good so let's keep
going
so okay when we try to understand this
construction we see that there are sort
of a variety of sort of interesting
interesting details okay sort of
subtleties the first one which is by far
the most important one is that and this
is by the way not just in our
construction but in any of these quantum
supremacy constructions said polynomial
interpolation is extremely sensitive to
additive error right so what I mean by
this is that you know if instead of
exactly computing the output probability
for these C theta these scrambled
circuits we get some approximation okay
then when we interpolate our our in
principle our our our you know
interpolated worst case point could be
way off okay so you know as a
consequence of the fact that polynomial
interpolation is sort of what not
well-conditioned are very sensitive to
additive error this severely constrains
the robustness of this average case
argument all right so if you look at my
my sort of interval picture here if this
is the output probability of the true
quantum circuit see that's the random
circuit that's what we want to argue is
hard and this is the output probability
of C prime is slightly nonunitary but in
general extremely close to p 0 of C
right then it turns out that we can only
show hardness to compute any point in
this tiny tiny red interval of weight of
width 2 to the minus n cubed ok so and
then it turns out so so far we've only
been talking about the hardness of
computing but it turns out that if we're
really interested in the hardness of
sampling
it suffices to to show that that it's so
if you want to prove hardness of
sampling it suffice is to show that
computing any point on this much wider
interval of length 2 to the minus n over
poly right is sharply hard to compute so
I guess what I want to say is that what
we've done so far is we've shown that
there's a little bit of robustness
around this truncated point okay but
it's sort of false exponentially short
of what we would need to go from the
hardness of computing to the hardness of
sampling okay
all right let's see maybe I should stop
for there are some questions so let's
see ah let's see okay there yeah I think
I'm going to keep going
so some okay so there may be other ways
of doing this the second the second
point which is which has already been
brought up is that this truncated
circuit C prime is ever-so-slightly
non-unitary okay it's not unitary you
know because we're taking a unitary
matrix and we're truncating its Taylor
series okay it's extremely close to the
outcome probability of our circuit
because you know the the Taylor's there
is very well approximates the actual
unitary but it's not it's not unitary
and so how do we motivate this right how
do we motivate that our result does not
you know gets that gives us something
that's not quite a unitary well we show
and this is actually the technical
result in our paper and one of the
technical results we show with respect
to this hardness of sampling level of
approximation you know the truncations
don't matter so what I mean is this and
this is actually a for a formal theorem
in the in the in the in the paper is
that you know if someone were to show
that this this part that you know it's
hard to output any point in this wider
interval of width 2 to the minus and
over poly then in some ways it doesn't
matter you know where the center of that
interval is if it's centered around the
actual output probability P 0 of C or if
it's really really close to it
essentially because we didn't just
choose this C prime arbitrarily it's
extremely close to the the output
probability okay so so
can actually make this form oh we show
that in other words outputting an
additive approximation of 2 to the N
over poly that's this that's this
hardness of sampling level right it's
hard with respect to the original
circuit see if and only if it's hard to
compute the heart be the truncated
circuit to that same level of accuracy
okay so I won't prove that but but the
idea with this is just that you know we
didn't construct this C prime completely
arbitrarily it's very close to the
original circuit C and we did this
purposely to get a result like this that
said look if you care about hardness of
sampling it doesn't matter if you're
talking about the truncation of the
unitary good any let's any questions
about that
okay it looks like I'm good so I'm gonna
keep going
I recently up work hardness has been
shown around the original output
probability so this is a nice row as a
nice result um so in particular we we do
know after this sort of follow-up work
which use is similar but but but you
know slightly different techniques that
out that computing the output
probability of a random clocking circuit
see itself is Sharpie hard but within
the same tiny tiny precision okay so in
other words if you compare the picture
the interval picture here to the
interval picture from the last slide the
only difference is that the red interval
moved a little bit and now it's centered
around the original output probability
but this is very nice work you know to
do this Romi's gives a new method to
interpolate between the worst case and
random circuit using what he calls the
Cayley path which stays unitary
throughout the entire entire path so
essentially it's a very similar style
argument but he changes the way he
interpolates between the random unitary
and the worst-case unitary and he does
so in a way that stays unitary and so
he's actually able to argue about the
output probability of the original
circuit okay okay great let's see I can
stop to pause or you can keep going it's
up to you
I can pause a little okay great let me
let me keep going okay so you know so
far
we've we've really only talked about you
know noise in terms of sort of
imprecision of the algorithm okay but
but that's sort of not all we might hope
for right so let me ask another question
which is that you know is it hard to
nearly exactly compute noisy circuit
probabilities right and so when we do
this we sort of have a fact that that
that seems like it might be a hard and
fast barrier for us right which is that
you know for many natural noise models
not all of them but for many of them you
know the output probability the output
distribution of an uncorrectable quantum
circuit sort of converges rapidly to the
uniform distribution right and that's
sort of what you'd expect yes sorry and
asked a good question
about if and only if if my understanding
was that the proof shows a necessary
condition for quantum supremacy uh-huh
with respect to respect to the proof
yeah and you said if and only if I just
I was wondering how both ways do you
really have both ways or yeah we do we
do really have both ways mm-hmm how does
the other direction work then necessary
condition to such details right now what
I will say is that they're actually very
similar proofs in both directions and
and they're basically the way the proofs
work is that these distributions are
constructed you know the distribution
over the truncated circuit that we end
up getting and they're ideal circuit
they're constructed in a very special
way so that they're very close to each
other a number of properties okay and so
in other words it's just what I was
saying before that we didn't we didn't
construct these these this truncated
circuit arbitrarily we chose it
specially so that it has properties that
make it very similar to the the you know
the totally horror and immed astre
bution and so the proofs in both
directions sort of use these properties
but I think I'm going to continue on if
that's okay with you
okay sure we can talk later
hardness okay great so I'm now
considering sort of this noisy question
and I'm saying that you might think a
priori that there wouldn't be any
hardness at all here asymptotically
because you know as a system size goes
to to infinity it's often the case for
these uncorrect annoys e quantum
circuits that the distribution sort of
converges rapidly exponentially quickly
in fact in the system size our in the
depth with with the to the uniform
distribution so how can there be
hardness there well there's sort of a
counterpoint intuition which which has
sort of become popular I think in the
community which is that maybe quantum
hardness is still present and sort of
tiny deviations from uniform right so in
other words there's this sort of hard
quantum signal and as the noisy as the
noisy quantum circuit sort of progresses
and we're not correcting noise it's sort
of exponentially it gets exponentially
diminished right but but maybe it's
still somehow there if we if we sort of
if we sort of are precise enough right
so let's try to formalize this and I
want to say that the way we formalize
this will be pretty weak okay it's not
everything we would want and one day I
want to be very careful in saying this
but it's a starting point I think which
is that let's say we fix the noise model
ahead of time and we know what that
noise is so for example maybe each ideal
gate CI is followed by a two qubit
depolarizing noise with a certain
depolarizing parameter okay
so so here's the depolarizing channel
okay and and you know that another way
of saying that is we can kind of think
about choosing a noisy random circuit in
the following way right we first pick an
ideal random circuit from the random
circuit distribution okay and then the
environment are something that's sort of
not up to us chooses these M noise
operators from a distribution that's
specified by the channel so for us these
are you know the this is M you know two
qubit unitary operators or poly matrices
because we're talking about the
depolarizing channel right and then at
the end of the day we should think of
getting a sample from the output
distribution of this sort of combined
circuit this n dot C or dot is just you
know gate wise multiplication right with
ever learning what the noise operators
are right so that's sort of the model I
have in mind and you know one thing
that's really nice about this is you can
see by linearity that you can write the
output probability of the noisy quantum
circuit as an expectation over the noise
operators of the output probability of
this circuit C dot M right excuse me n
dot C right and then what's really nice
about this furthermore is that this can
be written this expectation can be
written as a weighted sum of Fineman
path integrals right so I'm just writing
out what this expectation is and the key
point is that this is still a polynomial
of degree 2 m in the ideal gate entries
so you know we've added terms to this to
this Fineman path integral but rather to
this the sum but it still has the
property that we cared about okay
so by the same arguments as before we
actually do have a worse two average
case reduction for computing the output
probability of this noisy quantum
circuit to within tiny tiny tolerance
like 2 to the minus n cubed okay but let
me also say that you know before we even
get to the point and that we can also
establish worst-case hardness here in
this context I almost feel like this
tiny precision that we're getting is
sort of more justified because we know
at the same time for constant rate
depolarizing noise that the error sorry
that the distribution is converging
exponentially to the uniform
distribution so I think it sort of makes
sense that we would require super tiny
precision okay because obviously the
uniform distribution is not hard even I
can compute an output output probability
of the uniform distribution on n qubits
right okay great
so so but all we've shown so far is you
know if we can compute this quantity for
a random circuit see we can also compute
this for a worst case see that's all
we've done right so there's sort of an
interesting question then which is well
how hard is the worst-case circuit right
in other words is it hard to compute the
output probability of a noisy quantum
circuit and see if we average over the
noise but the worst-case circuit is
fixed okay and what's really nice is
actually
one of the only times in my life where I
sort of had this question and then it's
already been solved essentially uh so it
turns out that that Fujii writing in
2016 had already essentially solved this
question and what he shows is that it's
it's this is this this you know this is
sharp be hard this computed outcome
probability of a worst case noisy
quantum circuit if it's possible to
error detect okay so in other words if
the gate error rate the depolarization
parameter Q is below a constant error
detection threshold okay so it's a sort
of a nice result it's a simple but nice
but nice argument and it will be sort
let me try to you know tell you how this
works the the proof technique will be
familiar to anyone who has seen prior
quantum supremacy arguments which is
that sort of suffice is to be able to
show the universality of noisy quantum
circuits under post-selection right so
that that's suffice is to show that this
this output probability is hard and and
what fuji says is the following i'm
paraphrasing of course wildly but
roughly this is the idea well let's
suppose we have this noisy circuit but
we have both the ability to post select
and the ability to detect errors right
well then why don't we combine these two
sort of superpowers and and post select
on the syndrome measurement outcomes
corresponding to no error occurring all
right so if you do this then it's clear
that you get you know if you can if you
can note for sure that you didn't have
any error and you can post select on you
know exponentially improbable
measurement outcomes then it's it's
actually clear in this setting that you
can get hardness and that that actually
that finishes the proof that's sort of a
two sentence summary of of what he does
but the interesting thing here is that
you don't need error correction right
and you it's it's it suffice is to get
error detection which could be a lower
detection threshold which could be a
lower threshold right but what I'll say
is there is a caveat which I think is is
very interesting to try to ask if this
is necessary or not which is that this
requires a huge overhead in in number of
qubits to error detect nearly perfectly
so if we really wanted to implement his
scheme you know we would we would need
in a day
overhead of a polynomial number of
qubits and it's it's rarer detect really
perfectly so that what you need is at
the end of the day if you see no errors
you know if your syndrome measurements
indicate you have no errors that the
idea that the output probability of the
error detected circuit is like
exponentially close to the ideal circuit
which is very demanding but what I want
to say is that nonetheless as a
consequence of combining these two
results I think it's pretty nice that we
can say computing the output
probabilities of noisy random quantum
circuits is actually classically hard as
long as the noise per gate is below this
error detection threshold that's that's
what we get when we combine these two
results I think there's a lot of really
interesting work to do here to ask if
this is somehow optimal in some sense or
if we can do even better than this you
know at some lower threshold okay okay
great so should I take questions here
okay
so Google should be testing whether
noise is below the error detection
threshold target even though it's not
useful
woman error detection and see if it
helps in medicating hair it's a good
thing yeah that's that's a message and
of course there are a lot of drawbacks
of these results there they require
overhead and so on it's sort of still I
would say in a theoretical these are
theoretical results but that is sort of
a high level message that we're trying
to trying to say it's some some pretty
high level okay okay great and and I
think another thing that's really
interesting about this like I said
before is purely theoretical it's that
you know this sort of might tell you why
there's a barrier in extending these
arguments and making these average case
results more robust right because we
know that that at some point this
quantity is very is is is well
approximated by the uniform distribution
right and so this is sort of saying that
we can't make you know there's not at
least in this setting there's not going
to be just a sort of turnkey way of
making these average worse to average
case results more robust okay because we
know that their robustness is false at a
certain point because the uniform
distribution is easy to approach
so that I think is an interesting
message here too that has nothing
whatsoever to do with experiment okay
great
so okay great so I have a little bit of
time I want to tell you just briefly
about some new results that I'm pretty
excited about and so I'm so you know I'm
a complexity theorist of course I'm
interested in hardness but we're also
really interested in easiness results
and these are of course sort of flip
sides of the same coin
i but you know in particular we're
inspired by these by many recent
classical simulation results for
restricted classes of quantum circuits
you've just heard one of the ones that
we were really excited about this result
of of nap and and Aaron Harrow and so on
you know and and and we're going to
focus on kind of a related but different
topic okay which is we're going to
consider a very simplified setting of
random sir it's not really applicable I
think to quantum supremacy directly
which is 1d random circuits with horror
and 'm two qubit gates and local
depolarizing noise okay
it's very similar to what I was talking
about except we're talking about 1d
setting instead of 2d setting okay which
of course makes a big difference and I
want to be clear that what I'm about to
say is not directly relevant to the
Google experiment except maybe by some
very loose analogy okay now but I want
to I want to recall something which if
you have you know a constant rate of
depolarizing noise the output
distribution of the random circuit is
eventually going to converge to uniform
okay now before we were talking about
well at least in the 2d setting we can
sort of look at asymptotic behavior and
ask if there's a if there's still this
tiny quantum signal that's surviving
even though it's exponentially
suppressed here I'm I want to ask you of
a different question this is a more
pragmatic question which which is the
following
oops okay a more pragmatic question
which is for a given fixed error rate
what's the hardest depth to implement or
system signs to implement and where do
quantum correlations peak okay so this
is not an asymptotic question this is a
non asymptotic question it's a vague
question as currently formalized but
it's important right other words what
really is if you if you tell me that the
error
is something what is the right depth to
implement or system size to implement
and so as you might imagine you have to
do this numerically and and when we do
this you know we don't fully understand
these results theoretically but I think
we have some interesting plots I'd like
to show I'd like to show you let me tell
you a little bit more first about about
these results we're going to consider
what we call the MPO entanglement
entropy of the resulting mixed state
after we apply this noisy circuit I'm
not going to define very carefully what
this what this measure is this
entanglement reviews some people
probably know and know it already it's
it's called different things in the
literature sometimes it's called an
operator and entanglement or something
like this the point is it's a measure of
quantum correlations between two
disjoint subsets of qubits and it
reduces to the standard and Engelmann
entropy measure in the special case of
pure states which is sort of nice
furthermore the reason we chose this
quantity is because it turns out to
determine the cost of classical MPO
simulation okay so it turns out you know
it sort of gives an upper bound on on
the classical complexity of computing
the output probability we can do this in
time that scales exponentially in turns
out the maximum MPO entanglement entropy
or the maximum here is taken over the
system over the subsystem length okay
but essentially it's because this this
this entropy measure can be used to
bound the required bond dimension chi
needed to accurately describe a mixed
state sort of you know talking about
hours for truncations and and so
essentially these MPO techniques they
run in in pollen time polynomial and N
and Chi and so in general we have to
think of them as running exponentially
in this this entanglement measure okay
so that's that's sort of the only thing
I want to talk about with regard to this
measure we sort of wrote a whole bunch
about it and you can read more in our
paper but I want to show you some
interesting plots which I think are are
very fun to look at so so we have three
of them here and there's many more in
our paper but what we're doing is each
each plot has a different fixed to qubit
error rate P so otherwise they're
exactly there
laughing the same information but the
the depolarization parameter the the
noise strength is is is different and is
fixed in each graph okay
maybe each graph for graphing the
circuit depth on the x-axis and this and
this MPO entanglement entropy measure on
the y-axis okay some measure of quantum
correlations that again gives us an
algorithm that runs exponentially at
that time and and then and then we're
doing is each each color here each line
corresponds to a different system size
take which goes from n equal four to n
equal 18 and and each each point in the
plot is averaged over 24 different
random circuits ok so what we what we
see is is the following which i think is
not super surprising for each error rate
okay so each fixed graph there's sort of
a peak depth at which correlations are
maximized okay so you can you can see
that you know it for example here at the
error rate 0.15 you see that it around
depth around depth 5 for all the system
sizes they're sort of simultaneously
maximized their their entanglement
measure and and what's more which I
think we found sort of interesting I
don't quite understand this
theoretically yet is it seems like at
this peak depth after a sufficiently
large system size you know adding more
qubits doesn't actually change this in
this entanglement entropy measure right
so there really is a sense in which you
know after you fix the gate rate it
doesn't seem like it helps you to
increase your system size right and you
can see this very clearly for example in
this plot here if you can see my mouse
it's when we go from system size 4 to
system size 6 we're sort of slightly
increasing our entropy measure but then
you know after a certain point you know
after after sighs like around 8
no we're really not seeing any increase
in in this particular measure right and
we see this in each and every one of
these plots about the same thing right
and again that I I don't I don't
actually have a theoretical explanation
for that I think the fact that this the
shape of the curve is like this I think
that's clear I mean essentially what's
happening is you know when
have uncorrect avoids your converging -
you know a maximally mixed state that's
going to be a uniform distribution it
doesn't have quantum correlations that
this that this measure is is is
measuring but but the fact that it sort
of you know there's like for each gate
for each gate error rate there seems to
be like a peak size and after that
you're not gaining that's something I
think is sort of interesting and I don't
understand that very well theoretically
yet okay so from the perspective of this
particular algorithm once we fix the
noise rate the hardness seems to
saturate at a fixed system size okay
let's see it one more time and then I'll
wrap up so to see the saturation
behavior more directly we can we can
plot the number of qubits versus this
this entanglement entropy measure at the
optimal depth okay so remember for each
gate error rate we have an optimal depth
and each curve here represents a
different error rate at the optimal
depth for that error rate from the prior
plot and what we see pretty clearly here
is it seems like there's a maximum
system size that's determined entirely
by the error rate after which we don't
gain in quantum correlations according
to this measure this is happening for
each one of these gate error rates so
for example if you look at point O six
here you know it seems like we're
increasing our correlations until we get
to around I don't know eleven twelve
qubits and then we sort of flatten okay
and that happened that happens for each
one for all of these gate error rates
individually the only difference is that
where that peak is happening the peak
system size is is different and as you
would expect as the gate error rate it's
worse the sort of number of qubits that
that sort of you know we flattened that
it's lower in lower right and so that's
what we're seeing here okay great so let
me just conclude so numerically who sort
of observed that noisy for noisy 1d
random circuits there's a sense in which
quantum correlations peak at a
particular system size we can make use
of this observation to compute the noisy
output probabilities using matrix
product operator methods but on the
other hand we can prove that sort of in
this very different asymptotic regime
you know computing noisy output
probabilities to vary
precision is hard and 2d below a noise
threshold and that's combining our
results with the results of Fuji ok
great so let me up here and thanks to
you know many of my collaborators for a
lot of useful conversations about this
topic great thank you Bill